well things are getting interesting at
the ellen degeneres show
three days after news broke that the
show was under investigation for
allegations of a hostile work
environment
ellen addresses the staff i love
making people happy i can't do the
things you do
because i'm the be kind girl i think
that i was a nice person to begin with
and i hope i've gotten nicer
i am disappointed i am sorry
those are the words in ellen's apology
letter responding to recent allegations
that her show is a
toxic workplace and has a culture of
fear
e.t obtained a copy of the letter where
ellen says my name is on the show and
everything we do
and i take responsibility for that as
we've grown
exponentially i've not been able to stay
on top of everything
and relied on others to do their jobs as
they knew i'd want them done
clearly some didn't that will now change
the apology seems to hit certain beats
that i think were definitely advised by
a legal team what's interesting about
the apology is that she seems to have
blamed sort of a set of people or
advisors
comedian brad garrett wasn't having it
the everybody loves raymond star
tagged ellen's show and tweeted sorry
but it comes from the top
no more than one who were treated
horribly by her common knowledge
i think that brad sort of said what many
people inside the industry
were thinking ellen's staff apology came
after an internal investigation was
launched but just hours before another
explosive article was published
last night buzzfeed after speaking to 36
former employees claimed
three executive producers engaged in
rampant
sexual misconduct and harassment so
almost instantly within eight days of
this investigation sources told us that
a top ellen producer will not be joining
the show when it comes back in the fall
this morning justin bieber's manager
scooter braun came to ellen's defense
calling her a kind
thoughtful courageous human being
meanwhile australian radio host
neil breen said he had a difficult
experience working with ellen's
producers
when she appeared on the today show
there in 2013.
the producers called us aside and said
no one's to talk to ellen you don't talk
to her you don't approach her
you don't look at her oh i can't look at
her i found the whole thing bizarre
i think it's anyone's guess uh how long
you know actually ellen can stay
uh stay and stay comfortably on the air
with what's been put out there so far